you're feeling a little hot under the
romper it's because today is the 10-year
anniversary of some famous nudes being
leaked normally you'd get into trouble
for ten-year-old nudes but this is a
piece of internet history so comedians
who to the well-aged NSFW pics belong to
a paul giamatti be Queen Elizabeth Sea
Air Bud Murray Giamatti let's find out
oh my gosh you guys just like education
rules can you believe it can you believe
it he thought I was getting one thing is
mcafee Socrates can you even fun you
believe it it's like it's why he finally
gave it up yeah tonight yeah Internet's
greatest meme turned 10 this week
although it doesn't look a day over 8
and during its run and is amass tons of
fans including the first lady
[Applause]
[Music]
that is that all right that is right up
there with her other famous prank
pretending to love her husband hilarious
by the way I got double rickroll because
we do have those leaked giamatti nudes
if you guys want to see him see the
[Applause]
taking on the set of John Adams